yacht au monde ce plaisir je me retrouve
sur jeff the killers new games est parti
alors première chose qu'on peut dire sur
le jeu je pense qu'on est tous d'accord
qu'est ce que c'est que cette interface
que se passe-t-il
est-ce qu'on est en 2001 sur un jeu de
2001 non non voyez ce parti alors ça jeu
apparemment il fait peur d'où le nom
jason keller donc déjà situé pile et
petits que tu quittes ce jeu tout de
suite ça mais c'est carrément rim aime
pas de lan mais sa keynote bon alors aux
prêts center to use je peux utiliser ce
bras est ce que c'est une blague
we enter s'est rien passé quoi d'accord
eh ben c'est super une je viens de
refaire ma chambre elle est pas belle
bon allez on y va alors où oulala non
[ __ ] mais c'est effectivement elle est
juste horrible bon c'est la poignée qui
fait 10 mètres
oui oui quand même
ah ah c'était bien une clé tout est
multiplié par dix dans ce jeu tout est
beaucoup plus gros est ce qu'on peut se
laver les mains puisque c'est bien
dégueulasse non
alors on a de la vie en haut à gauche on
à 2002 vie
est ce que cet homme était jack the
killers est ce que ce cube a été dit
elle ce qui leur prêtent à key to open
ok c'est bon
elle a été là voilà pourquoi arrêter là
ça non plus ça me détruit les oreilles à
chaque fois donc j'ai baissé le son du
jeu là et c'est ça le jeu sais-tu marché
plutôt que des jump scare comme ça hop
boumal en avance ah non là comme par
hasard au moins du monde ça ne marche
jamais bon bonjour la fête est déjà
finie je danse c'est bien là je remets
mes fesses totalement page pourquoi je
dis ça alors on what blessés car
n'importe quoi et je tire fait avec
after effects en 1998 un ter toulouse
bon si je crois que oui les réflexes et
tout est tombé sur un ton de foot
attention
allez hop rock et rocket to open media
pas d'une clé à dans les toilettes ou
par contre si les nouvelles arènes et je
suis super g ce qui me fait plutôt peur
alors non on peut pas volontaire on ne
peut rien faire à part entre ce tonneau
et joue au toboggan
ouais c'est [ __ ] mais c'est carrément
c'est carrément nul à chier comme jeu
finalement qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
les trottoirs on t'a jamais dit qu'il
faut faire attention trottoir à et à la
rouille aussi vieux [ __ ] il ya des
clés cachés un peu partout à mon avis
alors est-ce qu'on n'a pas en plus
maintenant j'arrête pas de faire à
épines clichés vers la non bon il ya des
espèces de c'est quoi ces substances
inconnues des bouts de verre ou alors
des hiéroglyphes et par des hommes
préhistoriques
non alors ça c'est très flou ça ça c'est
pour danser voilà c'était la danse jour
peut-être là non la baille de balle le
plus impressionnant du monde ce pistolet
fidh
on prend notre faucher ont tué du blé
nous comment ça se passe mais bordel
vous allez me dire où aller je t'en fous
tu plais bandama car lorsque je suis un
gros gros buzz qui trouve pas une clé à
super simple à trouver ou soit cette clé
est sur un autre jeu voilà peut pas
tenir une clé lui
merde quoi tu as un brad était accrochée
au mur et tu ne sers à rien si j'avais
des belges pour y tirer dessus
petit coup
ah ah d'accord donc ça fait vingt
minutes que je galère alors qu'en fait
ils disent la porte est verrouillée il
faut une clé je n'ai pas de clé et ça
c'est ouvre donc qu'est ce que c'est que
ce verrou ou bien ils ont acheté leader
price ou bien un souci
voilà par contre j'ai plus de bâle 1
white
wait pourquoi cette musique 1 pourquoi
ce que voulaient du thé je vous enserre
ok alors c'est moi tranquille
pauvre le frigo selon pas le réflexe de
gros quoi je comprends fois leur frigo
non j'ai tout se joue alors bon les mecs
on est dans cette scène qu'est ce qui se
passe absolument rien derrière on est
d'accord
ouais d'accord allons nous en tout cas
on marche au ralenti exclu
ok donc là il marche et là il court no
koi et marchent ils marchent pas en fait
il ya deux mika christophe ricetti
personnage qui va faire peur ça va être
un tube
c'est le personnage qui à faire peur ça
va être un cube est ce que tu étais bien
aux à tête
[ __ ] voilà j'aime un fait ça aille
vite et pas contre lyon jeff les take
that est non
juste nul on fait quoi jane complète et
c'est la fin et c'était bien nul à chier
a alors je vous propose de ne pas jouer
à ce jeune je me suis fait avoir tout
comme vous et puis à bientôt
mais l' avantage de cet homme
et qui peut tirer la chasse d'eau avec
ses dents voilà comme ça
quelle marche du château
peut aussi regarder